One super cool thing to me about
spectral partitioning is that you can
derive it using the graph laplacian
as it appears in a particular
physical system.
Imagine that you have a bunch
of sticks of infinite length.
Let's suppose the sticks
are fixed meaning they don't move.
This dashed line is just a reference.
We're going to measure distances
relative to the reference.
And suppose each stick has
a weight attached to it.
And let's suppose each weight
has a mass of little m.
We're talking about a physical system so
the mass would be measured in, say,
kilograms.
And for simplicity, let's assume
all the weights have the same mass.
Now imagine that you connect
these weights by springs so
then if you take all the weights and
you displace them by some amount
relative to one another,
the strings will stretch.
And the weights will move up and down.
So what I want us to do is study
the motion of these weights.
Let's zoom in on one of the weights.
Now, relative to the reference line,
weight i will be displaced by
some amount at any point in time.
Let's call this
displacement x of i of t.
Now, in Physics 101, you would have
analyzed the motion of these weights,
using Newton's laws and
Hooke's laws for springs.
Yaaar, did someone say springs?!
Here's a quick reminder.
Newton's Law says that the net
force acting on a object
causes it to accelerate in
linear proportion to its mass.
Hooke's Law says that the force
from a spring is proportional to
how much it stretched.
Hooke's Law holds if this
degree of stretching or
displacement is relatively small.
Now, if that all sounds like a bunch of
nonsensical mumbo jumbo, don't worry,
I'm not testing you on physics.
Just hang in there with me, and
I promise something neat will happen.
So let's go back to this ith weight.
Its motion is determined by
the net force acting on it.
By Hooke's Law,
that force will depend on how much
the strings are being stretched.
And in fact, each string will
be stretched by the difference
between the displacements of the masses.
So, the right-hand side is
just the sum of these forces.
Now, rewriting the right-hand
side you'll get the following.
Notice the values of the coefficients.
So, the net force acting on
a given mass is proportional to
the displacements of its neighbors.
In fact,
I can rewrite this entire system for
all the masses as a system
of differential equations.
Let's define a vector x arrow,
whose components are all
the springs displacements.
Then the entire system of differential
equations can be written in
the following form.
I've used matrix notation here to
express the entire system very
compactly.
So, does this matrix look familiar?
Why it's nothing more
than a graph laplacian.
In particular, it's the graph
laplacian for a line graph.
I know what you're thinking,
okay Vudoc, what on God's green earth
does this have to do with partitioning?
Therein lies the neat surprise.
Start by asking yourself what would
the motion of this system of weights and
springs look like?
The top plot is the displacement
of all the weights.
Every weight is a dot and the springs
are the solid lines connecting the dots.
The bottom plot will show you
the velocity of all of the weights.
At the beginning suppose we give
a little kick to the middle weight so
that its velocity is one unit
of distance per unit of time and
the other weights are at
rest with velocity zero.
That's how you read the initial
picture shown in the bottom plot.
So from this starting point,
let's see what happens.
Notice how the springs are bobbing up
and down with a kind of wavy motion.
In fact,
this motion can always be described
as a sum of fundamental displacements.
Which are basically sines and
cosine curves at various
fundamental frequencies or modes.
If you have a background in music,
you know about harmonics,
and harmonics are modes for
say, vibrating strings.
Now for this particular spring system,
it turns out that the fundamental modes
are given by the eigenvectors
of the graph laplacian.
In fact, when we finally arrive
at our ultimate algorithm for
spectral partitioning, you'll be taking
a closer look at the eigenvectors.
But more on that later.